i will say directly no i will not go
sport and politics are indivisible
those who take a stand like muhammad ali
refusing to fight in vietnam
have found themselves exiled but this
was the year
protest went mainstream naomi osaka the
world's highest-paid female athlete
wore the name of a black woman killed by
police in kentucky
and anthony joshua marched on the
streets of watford
a movement which originated in america
quickly spread
athletes had never exercised collective
power
like this the power of players these
days
in this country or in sport in general i
think has only been
realized in the last 12 months since
george floyd's death
players realize that if we want to do
something whether it be
support the nhs and give a donation of
our wages whether it be
wearing black lives matter on our shirts
whether it be taking a knee
if all the players are kind of
in unity
there's not really much that anybody can
say in america
the atlanta dream basketball team
protested their
own owner kelly loffler who was also the
state
senator she had called the black lives
matter movement
marxist and divisive and so the players
campaigned for her political rival
reverend rafael warnock went from being
way down in the polling
to being elected these women had helped
the democrats win the senate
when you're in a minority group or in a
group that's
more marginalized like you're inherently
political and you can't do anything
about that so
i think there's a luxury in being able
to say like oh keep politics out of
sports when this affects
our reality and our humanity it's
difficult to believe
it's only five years since american
football player colin kaepernick
was cast aside by the nfl for refusing
to sing the national anthem
in a protest against racism and police
brutality
now brands are actively seeking out
athletes who take a stand
as long as it's genuine if you have a
natural
authentic voice as marcus rashford did
then it can have a very positive impact
he grew up in a low-income family
his mother worked full-time but still
wasn't able to always put food on the
table for them
so he knew exactly what that experience
was like and he was therefore able to
talk about it with
a great level of insight athlete
activism
isn't a new phenomenon but the unrest
following george floyd's murder has
turbocharged the power they wield in
society
their voice has never been louder martha
kellner sky news